what's going on guys this is rob and i
want to give a quick thanks to noom for
sponsoring this video who we'll talk
about here in a second but
we need to establish something the
beyonders need to exist in the marvel
cinematic universe they need to be in
the marvel cinematic universe and not
because of some moral philosophical
quandary or this thing that makes us
look at ourselves introspectively and
experience a kind of existential crisis
what is the meaning of it all the
beyonders need to be in the mcu
because they're cool man and they killed
the multiverse okay look here's the
thing right like
the beyonders destroyed the multiverse
like literally they killed the
multiverse well technically it was
doctor doom who did it but the beyonders
were going to do it he just did it first
we'll explain that kind of to a degree
right here's the thing man
the marvel cinematic universe so far has
been pretty tame even with the
multiverse coming in but something that
i want to specify here there is nothing
you've seen in the marvel cinematic
universe that has ever been even almost
kind of possibly depending on the
circumstance slightly remotely close
to the power of the beyonders thanos
with the infinity gauntlet he's a kid
with a pop gun thanos with the infinity
gauntlet could take on like galactus
right he could handle galactus he
probably could have handled the
celestials and maybe he did i don't
really know but like those are cosmic
entities right they are less powerful
than the infinity gauntlet if thanos
came running up on the beyonders with an
infinity gauntlet they would be like huh
and then bam right just lay this smack
down on that guy in no uncertain terms
but before we get into our discussion
about the beyonders i do want to talk
about new so nume is what i like to
refer to as a food psychological suite
in the sense that noom basically helps
you understand the psychology behind why
it is that you eat the way you do for me
as a person it wasn't simply enough to
just track calories i wanted to
understand why i ate the kind of foods
that i did the psychology that went
behind it is it really just that that
bag of chips is amazing or is there
something subconscious going on and the
daily classes that nume offers
really help me to understand what's
going on behind the scenes in my
subconscious when it comes to eating the
kind of things that i eat and why i eat
those things in excess a really good
example of this is a class they have
called breaking the behavior chain and i
absolutely loved this class because one
of the things that it taught is that
usually people when it comes to the
psychology and basically coping
mechanisms food is a very popular coping
mechanism but it usually starts with
some kind of a trigger this trigger can
be environmental it can be a result of
your childhood some kind of a background
but understanding where that comes from
is tantamount to being able to fix it
and that's the benefit of new that's the
biggest benefit of noom as far as i'm
concerned is getting a better
understanding of yourself because if you
can trace those those unhealthy habits
back to a singular point and then you
can understand how to correct that that
sets you on the road for lasting change
so that noon science-backed approach not
simply just helps you track what it is
that you're eating they also help you to
change your life to change your goals
and to get yourself on the path of a
healthier lifestyle so make sure you
guys check the link in the description
or go to noom.com geek culture to take
your free evaluation and it's really
really quick and easy it's not
complicated at all i promise but that's
noom.com
geek culture g-e-e-k
[Music]
c-u-l-t-u-r-e i can't spell
[Laughter]
but make sure you guys check that out
let's get back into our video so talking
about the beyonders here's the thing
about this right here's a crazy thing uh
let's kind of wind the clock back a
little bit because there is a bit of an
original explanation about the beyonders
and then we'll talk about how we can put
them in the mcu but there is a bit of an
original explanation which doesn't
necessarily apply to the comics anymore
but it can apply to the marvel cinematic
universe and in fact
it fits in perfectly and if anything the
marvel cinematic universe has already
actually already set the stage for the
beyonders to be introduced into the the
marvel cinematic multiverse now right
the mcm i guess we can call it that the
marvel cinematic multiverse i don't
doesn't have the same ring as the mcu
maybe it's nostalgia i don't really know
but here's the thing the original
explanation that was given to us is that
there was an event that took place in
marvel comics which i think was either
the pre-scroll war or maybe operation
galactic storm i can't remember which
one but basically it drew the attention
of the beyonder this being who just
existed out there and was just
incredibly powerful literally in the
original secret wars in 1984 it was a
booming voice from the sky it was like a
tear in space like the voice of god
snatched up all the heroes all the
villains said fight to the death and
whoever wins i'll make your wildest
dream come true ultimately doctor doom
stole the power of the beyonder and then
basically brought the conflict to an end
and then the beyonder got his powers
back and then ran and then we got secret
wars 2 when the beyonder was more
curious about people so it showed up on
earth dressed like john travolta from
saturday night fever not even lying they
looked exactly alike it was it was kind
of uncanny i guess it was the style back
then and then there came a point when uh
the beyonder
spent time with uh woman of the night
it was a different time it was the 1980s
the rules were a little more relaxed
back then
now fast forward a little bit to
fantastic four issue number 319 and what
this did is actually change the original
explanation of how the beyonder
basically arrived in the marvel universe
in the first place but what basically
happened here is that there was a guy
named owen reese who was by all
standards of measurement a loser and
this guy worked at a place called the
acme atomic corporation and that he had
inadvertently created a cosmic cube and
that the way cosmic cubes work is that
they're essentially portals right you
can rip a hole in space and time that
will basically grant you access to the
beyond verse and that energy from the
beyond verse would pour into a
containment device usually in the shape
of a cube and then it was equal to the
infinity gauntlet in power and depending
on who was writing the story sometimes
more powerful but you could basically do
anything with it what owen reese did is
he accidentally opened a portal to the
beyond verse but because there was no
containment unit for that energy to pour
into what ended up happening is half of
it went into owen reese and the other
half just went on to the universe
eventually became sentient and then
became the beyonder so that was the new
explanation of how the beyonder ended up
in the marvel universe now fast forward
to the single greatest comic book story
ever told jonathan hickman's avengers
new avengers sun
sun
single greatest comic book story ever
told i don't care what anybody says
right it's the the the great and the
first story arc the infinity gauntlet
gets destroyed i love oh my god
i'm sorry i'm so excited people but it
is an exciting story i love i love it
right captain america gets the infinity
gauntlet all the infinity stones get
destroyed uh like the time stone
vanishes and then reappears and it takes
captain america like 50 000 years in the
future it's it's it's just it's a
phenomenal story right the greatest
comic book story ever written in the
history of man i had something in my eye
for some now here's what happens right
there's there's the multiversal collapse
and all that kind of stuff but here's
where the beyonders come in spoilers for
a story that is
2015 16 17 18 19 20
21 22.
nine years old so here's the thing right
technically it's actually older than
that it's about 10 years old it started
in 2012. but uh but here's what ended up
happening right that basically what had
gone on is that the beyonder as it
originally appeared in secret wars 1984
was more of like a child unit but it was
a member of a larger race that was
astronomical in power and so when the
multiverse is collapsing everything's
coming to an end the incursions are
happening right so like universes are
crashing into each other being destroyed
all that kind of stuff the illuminati
it's like reed and all those guys
they're trying to figure out what's
going on one of the things that happens
is reid sends hank pem into the
multiverse to find the source of the
incursions or to find this this kind of
group that they've only ever heard of
but never actually seen before they were
referred to as the ivory kings or the
white lords of wild space they were they
had really really cool names right but
they had only ever heard of them right
there had been rumors about them
discussions of them they'd heard people
say them before but they never actually
seen what they look like and so what
ends up happening is hank pym goes out
into the multiverse and then there comes
a point
when he's traveling through and he comes
upon this battle where it's basically
the ivory kings right the white lords
the beyonders and they are killing the
cosmic entities and when i say killing i
mean it's a bloodbath right like it's
like stopping on an ant hill these
cosmic entities never had a chance and
they're killing all of them from across
every single universe right they're
killing them all across the multiverse
at the same time right they're killing
infinity eternity uh master order lord
chaos eon just all these guys galactus
they're all being obliterated by the by
the beyonders right it's only three of
them only three beyonders are killing
like it's literally one beyonder in one
universe one beyonder in another
universe and then another beyonder in a
third universe he only sees three
universes but literally one beyonder was
enough to wipe out all the cosmic
entities in any particular universe now
as this battle rages on it becomes
obvious how overpowered these beyonders
are because after all the cosmic
entities are killed the living tribunal
steps in right the living tribunal just
appears and hank pym almost goes crazy
by witnessing it all he's like this he's
like he's like i almost like he's
recapping this whole story to like
captain america and to tony stark and
reed richards and all these guys and
he's telling him all this and he's like
i almost went insane
just what just being in the presence of
the living tribunal i almost went nuts
experiencing this
and and ultimately he's like the
beyonders killed the living tribunal
they destroyed this thing just to get a
guy's preference leaving out like the
anomalies like protege marquee of death
people like that the living tribunal is
the second most powerful being next to
god right the one above all it's insane
how powerful the living tribunal is
anything it wants to do can be done and
the beyonders annihilated it and so at
that point hank pym's just like there's
nothing we can do like we we can't
defeat that level of power we can't
there's nothing the infinity gauntlet
man come on dude it'd be like throwing
pebbles at a whale there's nothing we
can do here it's not gonna do not gonna
make any difference there's no way for
us to stop that level of power they're
going to end the multiverse everything
is going to die it's hopeless here and
so what you end up finding out later on
is that when owen reese gained his
powers initially by accidentally
creating that cosmic cube that's a
universal constant in every universe
across the multiverse the molecule man
gains his powers the exact same way and
the reason why is because he was
engineered to be that way that seemingly
somewhere along the line whether it was
because of the original event that led
to the beyonder becoming curious and
then the other beyonders becoming aware
although historically speaking the
beyonders have actually had a lengthy
history in terms of their involvement in
uh in the marvel comics universe like
they they've been acting for quite some
time they were the ones who created the
original savage land they were
supposedly responsible for the creation
of all life in the universe it depends
on who's telling the story but
regardless that that the beyonders
themselves had basically engineered the
molecule man and made his origin the
exact same so he would be one half of a
cosmic cube because their intention was
to detonate every molecule man across
the multiverse just to see what would
happen because the destruction of that
molecule man would lead to the
destruction of the entire universe he
was literally a bomb and when he went
off the whole universe would go with him
they just wanted to blow up the whole
multiverse right blow them all up at the
same time just to see what happened a
grand science experiment and then of
course it basically led to doctor doom
and the molecule man ultimately
defeating the beyonders and then dr doom
stole the power of the beyonders and
literally became god king doom it was
pretty amazing he was all white he was
like he was like sitting on the tree of
idrisil right like the the world tree
from thor i mean it was it was crazy
right like no one was on the same level
of power well no i take that back when
black panther got the infinity gauntlet
he was he was seemingly on the same
level of power as doctor doom but it
didn't necessarily seem like it it was
not so it was it was secret wars 2015
was a crazy amazing story god i love
that story so much matter of fact once
i'm done with this i'm gonna go back
home and start reading again i loved
hickman's avengers and new avengers but
the thing about this is that you can
roll this over into the marvel cinematic
universe and it makes perfect sense it's
easily done it's so easily done because
let's say for example that we disregard
the fantastic four issue number 319
explanation and we go with the the
classic explanation right the classic
beyonder explanation and we say that
basically something happened in the
marvel cinematic universe multiverse
that made the beyonder aware of its
existence well we already have an answer
to that question sylvie killing he who
remains and the multiverse coming back i
mean an infinite expanse of possible
alternate realities just exploding into
existence
someone's gonna notice that right that's
not something that you just don't happen
to know about right you know i mean
unless you're in a universe you know but
if you're on the outside like the beyond
verse you're gonna notice that man this
little tiny speck that just suddenly
explodes outward yeah
that's gonna catch your attention
[Laughter]
now following that it's whatever we want
it to be it's whatever line of logic or
reason we want it to be we know the
russo brothers want to develop secret
wars from from like the 1984 version so
you can literally build on that right
you can say that like when the
multiverse suddenly just appeared out of
nowhere
that the beyonders sent one of their own
to investigate to see what it was right
to look inside and that's where secret
wars that the russo brothers would
direct basically came from that it's the
beyonder appearing we don't know the
back end we don't know that like there's
a beyond verse and the other beyonders
have sent him there or anything like
that we just simply know this nigh
omnipotent being that would just
dwarf the power of anything we've ever
seen before suddenly shows up and then
that movie unfolds however it unfolds
knowing the marvel cinematic universe
they'll kill the yonder and this is one
of those few instances when i actually
agree with them killing the villain uh
because what that would do is it would
draw the attention of the beyonders
they'd be honors will just kind of be
like damn they got that level of power
out there they killed one of us
okay like we got to see what's going on
and then by whatever manner and whatever
means it leads to them drawing the
conclusion that they have to destroy the
multiverse right they want to or it's an
experiment they don't really care about
anybody in it right they just want to
see what would happen if they did it's
like a kid burning ants with the sun in
a magnifying glass right like that's
what they want to do and so that leads
to basically the death of the multiverse
now here's the thing right the beyonders
showing up killing the cosmic entities
the eventual destruction of the
multiverse this could only really be
done if we get to the point where where
the marvel cinematic universe marvel and
disney are like we're done like we're
finished making movies like we're
basically done making movies we're not
going to make any more marvel movies i
don't really see that being a case
literally the marvel cinematic universe
is a license to print money so i don't
see disney being like you know what
we're tired of money now you know we've
grown bored of of just cash uh we want
to go explore the stars
i don't see that being the case and so i
imagine this is something they would do
if they wanted to reboot if they wanted
to say that like the multiverse will
always find a way to return right so
this is the the more the the modern day
equivalent of like the big bang right
the multiverse is destroyed and some
colossal multiversal calamity slash
conflict between the beyonders and
anybody else they want to invoke and
that ultimately the beyonders win and
the multiverse is totally destroyed but
like everything else in this world it
goes in cycles and that this energy has
to go somewhere so it coalesces and then
it explodes outward in a big bang and
gives birth to a new multiverse what do
you know new spider-man movies new iron
man movies new fantastic four movies all
that kind of stuff a complete and total
reboot of the marvel cinematic universe
this is something they could do in that
circumstance but barring those two
scenarios it's really hard to invoke
something like the beyonder and then
continue after that right it's really
hard to invoke a storyline where these
beings from beyond the multiverse with
just uh just
the power of god essentially
end up destroying the multiverse and
then things just kind of continue on
it's hard to make that work so with that
being said guys let me know what you all
think down in the comments section i'm
really curious what y'all's thoughts are
make sure you check out noom and i will
catch you all later
peace